accusé de fraude fiscale la banque
suisse ubs fixé sur son sort aujourd'hui
après une sanction record de 3 7
milliards d'euros en première instance
la cour d'appel de paris va trancher
dans le dossier dit des carnets de l'est
ubs est soupçonné d'avoir organisé un
système d' aide à l'évasion fiscale en
france entre 2004 et 2012 à l'origine
des poursuites de la justice française
est bien des lanceurs d'alerté parmi eux
stéphanie gibeau avec ce salarié du bs
en france elle est auteure de la traque
des lanceurs d'alerté elle est avec nous
ce matin
[Musique]
c'était fanny j beau bonjour bonjour
monsieur merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce matin sur rtl france
je le disais vous êtes l'une des
lanceurs n'alerte à l'origine des
poursuites judiciaires du bes vous allez
nous raconter votre rôle dans ce dossier
mais peut-être pour bien comprendre
qu'est ce qu'on reproche aux reproches
pardon concrètement aujourd'hui à ubs
alors il ya deux choses la première
c'est le démarchage illicite des
banquiers suisses sur le territoire
français donc ça s'appelle en langage
bancaire du démarchage et de l'autre
côté ce démarchage amène à de l'évasion
et la fraude fiscale est en fait tout
l'enjeu du procès ubs c'est justement de
valider ce qui a été les témoignages de
nombreux collaborateurs dont je fais
partie quel a été votre rôle vous dans
ce dossier
alors moi j'étais responsable marketing
et communication de la banque et pendant
une dizaine d'années j'ai organisé des
des événements ce qu'on peut appeler
plateforme événementielle pays paie pas
pour les clients fortunés de la banque
qui servait à la fois à fidéliser et de
l'autre côté à démarcher des des
prospects et s'avère que en 2008 suite à
une perquisition enduro de patrick de
faille est le directeur général
ma supérieure hiérarchique nouvellement
recrutés m'a demandé de détruire devant
disques durs et de mes archives tous les
fichiers qui comprenait le nom des
clients
qui avaient été invités pendant plus de
dix ans par la banque alors moi j'ai pas
vraiment compris ce qu'on me demande et
j'ai surtout vu comment on voulait
beaucoup et qu'on voulait se débarrasser
de moi et en fait j'ai tiré un fil qui
m'a fait comprendre qu'en fait la banque
m'avait mise en risque pendant plus de
dix ans puisque mon métier servait
justement à ce que ces banquiers suisses
viennent en france démarcher les clients
ça m'a valu
la carte isation harcèlement isolement
dépression enfin des problématiques
très difficile et puis à licenciement
bien évidemment à la fin le discrédit qu
ubs a fait porter sur moins value est ce
que ma carrière finalement souhaité
arrêter avec cette histoire mais si vous
voulez c'est loin d'être c'est loin
d'être gagné pour la banque parce
qu'elle a quand même perdu en réputation
énormément depuis depuis depuis dix ans
cette histoire a beaucoup
remué beaucoup d'encre vous savez qu'une
cellule de régularisation qui s'était
ouvert à berson verse à bercy où il ya
énormément de clients ubs qui sont venus
ce qui s'appelle se dégriser et que la
faire aujourd'hui est importante parce
que ubs a fait appel de la décision qui
avait été prise par la justice française
en 2019 de la condamner à l'amande
record de 4,5 milliards d'euros ubs
disant qu'elle est irréprochable nous
serons aujourd'hui à 13h30 si le
jugement en appel est confirmée qu'est
ce que vous attendez vous aujourd'hui ce
jugement
bien la fois confirmation de ce qui
avait été
annoncé en 2019 par la justice
il est évident que
il ya une crédibilité de la part de
de tout ce qu'on a pu
dénoncer moi j'ai quand même travaillé
pendant plus d'un an avec les douanes
françaises qui ont permis à ce que ce
procès ait lieu et que cette
condamnation ait lieu en première
instance en 2010 neuf donc moindre et
chez eux ce serait effectivement qu'une
une confirmation de cette condamnation
alors justement vous vous le dis vous
avez aidé ou poursuite 1 est-ce que vous
avez été soutenu par l'état français
dans vos démarches
jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'est silence radio
c'est à dire que tous les courriers que
je peux recevoir c'est qu'en fait je
n'aurais été de la part du ministère des
finances qu'un témoin dans le dossier
alors que comme vous savez un témoin ça
témoigne moi j'ai travaillé pendant plus
d'un an pour apporter des informations
sur ordre de fonctionnaires assermentés
alors que j'étais encore une
collaboratrice de la banque c'est à dire
que ce que m'a fait faire l'état est
quand même d'une
d'une violence inouïe j'étais obligé de
traîner les douanes donc l'état devant
les tribunaux et j'ai effectivement
gagné en 2018 il ya trois ans où j'ai
été reconnue collaboratrice du service
public donc à ce titre il était évident
que la france devait
rétribuer le travail que j'avais fait et
depuis trois ans et un refus
constant et perpétuelle donc non l'état
français qui se dit protégée les
lanceurs d'alert qui avait fait passer
cette fois sapin en 2016
qui vient là
de passer cette loi
de protection des lanceurs dallas suite
à la directive européenne
finalement a comme toujours beaucoup de
paroles et dans les actes ce qui se
passe strictement rien malheureusement
alors pour revenir sur le dossier ubs la
défense invoque des accords entre la
suisse et l'union européenne qui aurait
permis à ubs de prose proposer ses
services de défiscalisation ce que
l'union européenne a finalement une part
de responsabilité dans ce dossier
et je pense que le à la fois le
politique dans nos pays respectifs et au
niveau de l'europe est bien évidemment
responsable puisque ça fait qu'un en
comptant les paradis fiscaux aussi fini
qu'on entend notre adversaire c'est la
finance qu'on entend les uns et les
autres se lever contre contre certaines
pratiques et finalement tout perdu ont
regardé depuis l' affaire ubs qui dure
depuis 2007 2008 on a eu les panama
papers les pandora paper les paradise
papers les footballs x les marchés files
les
cetc perpétuelle donc si vous voulez si
le politique n'a pas mis le frein à
saint c'est soit elle et ces zones sont
impuissants soit qu'il a manque de
volonté soit les deux et on se retrouve
finalement avec des états surendettés on
se retrouve avec une classe moyenne qui
paye tout ce que les autres ne paye pas
et que bien évidemment il ya beaucoup de
il ya beaucoup de paroles il ya peu dax
c'est à dire qu'il ya un morcellement de
la classe politique en fonction des
parties des arts et des autres mais la
personne qui est d'accord pour parler
d'une seule voix contre ce fléau parce
que quand même nommer les choses comme
elles le sont merci beaucoup stéphanie
giraud d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin sur rtl france je le rappelle
vous êtes ex-salariés du bs en français
auteur de la traque des lanceurs d'alert
merci